The Truth About Equestrian Statues
You’ll often hear that the way a soldier’s
horse is portrayed in an equestrian statue
indicates how the soldier died.
This myth, perpetuated by many a tourist guide
the world over, simply isn’t true.
An example of a tourist guidebook that perpetuates
the equestrian myth is the 1987 Hands on Chicago:
“At Sheridan Road and Belmont Avenue, the
statue of [General] Sheridan beckons troops
to battle.
The horse General Sheridan rides is named
Winchester…
Winchester’s raised leg symbolizes his rider
was wounded in battle (the legs of [General]
Grant’s horse are on the ground, meaning
he was not wounded).”
This gives a pretty good account of the myth
as it is generally stated, but leaving out
the third commonly said option of the horse
having both front legs in the air, implying
the soldier died in battle.
Another caveat is that if the rider died of
complications from wounds received in battle,
but at a later date from the battle, most
versions of this myth have it that just one
leg should be up as with the people who were
wounded but didn’t die of complications
from the wound.
According to the U.S. Army Center of Military
History, no such tradition has ever existed.
This is not surprising considering that examples
of multiple equestrian statues of the same
person tend to be inconsistent in terms of
the horse’s legs positioning.
But let’s not take the U.S. Army historian’s
word for it, let’s look at some examples.
First, take a walk around Washington D.C.,
which has the largest collection of equestrian
statues of any city in the world.
From this, you’ll quickly be disabused of
the notion that the depiction of the horse’
legs has anything to do with the way the person
died, with only about 30% of this city’s
statues conforming to the aforementioned “rules”.
(Given that there are 3 options here, that
30% number seems rather fitting.)
One of the oldest known equestrian statues
in the United States is the 1853 statue of
General Andrew Jackson in Lafayette Park,
Washington D.C., which was made in celebration
of Jackson’s victory over the British at
the Battle of New Orleans.
In this statue, the horse has both forelegs
in the air.
Of course ,Jackson did not die in battle but
of tuberculosis.
The person who cast that sculpture, Clark
Mills, was the first sculptor in the United
States to cast a horse with a rider where
the horse has some of its legs in the air
(in this case both)- at this point it was
more of a mark of the skill of the artist
to have the horse with legs in the air rather
than any sort of tradition relating to battle
and death.
In cases where the same sculptor made multiple
equestrian statues that could potentially
apply to this “rule”, such as the case
of world renowned Irish sculptor Augustus
Saint-Gaudens, we see that he at times violated
the supposed tradition and other times seemed
to adhere to it.
One such statue he made of General William
Techumsa Sherman has one of the front legs
of the horse raised.
Indeed, General Sherman was wounded twice
in battle, and even had 3 horses shot out
from under him.
He did not die in battle, but lived to the
ripe old age of 71, and is thought to have
died from pneumonia.
So from that respect, this one fits.
It should be noted, though, that this statue
also has one of the horse’s rear legs lifted.
The equestrian statue horse legs myth doesn’t
seem to cover what that potentially would
mean… maybe… just maybe… it means the
horse is supposed to look like it’s running
and has nothing to do with the rider’s death/wounds…
There is also a major equestrian statue of
General Sherman at the General Sherman Memorial
in Washington D.C.
This statue has the horse with all four legs
on the ground.
(This is a common theme where multiple equestrian
statues exist.
One would guess the differences have something
to do with sculptors wanting theirs to look
markedly different than the already existing
statue(s).)
The only place where this equestrian statue
“tradition” seems to hold with any sort
of consistency is with a few statues of soldiers
who fought in the Battle of Gettysburg.
(This is thought to be how the myth got started
in the first place.)
Of the nearly 500 monuments at Gettysburg,
there are 6 equestrian statues.
Five of the six conform to the myth and the
sixth loosely does, but the problem is the
statue of General John Sedgwick, who died
at the Battle of Spotsylvania Court House-
his equestrian statue has all four hooves
are on the ground.
(Aside: General Sedgwick’s reported last
words were: “What?
Men dodging this way for single bullets?
What will you do when they open fire along
the whole line?
I am ashamed of you.
They couldn’t hit an elephant at this distance.”
He then took a bullet through his head fired
from about 900 meters (1000 yards) away.)
Of course, it could be argued that this “tradition”
was meant only to refer to what happened at
the battle of Gettysburg, in which Sedgwick
was not wounded nor did he die in.
If that’s the case, then his is correct.
However, if that’s the case then the statue
of James Longstreet in that collection is
not.
He wasn’t wounded in Gettysburg, but his
statue has the horse with one foot raised.
(He was wounded in the Battle of Glendale,
so that would fit there, but not if we’re
limiting the statue’s positioning based
on the battle of Gettysburg to make the statue
of General Sedgwick fit.)
Even then, it seems odd such a code would
be created just for 6 statues of prominent
people who fought in the battle of Gettysburg,
and even more odd that if the code did exist
that they would have broken it in one of the
statues.
Given there is no record of the sculptors
having done this intentionally, and the discrepancy,
it’s really not clear that this is what
they were going for.
It’s possible given the small sample size
and that this is the only place we find this
somewhat consistent correlation, it just randomly
happened to work out that way with the way
the sculptors decided to make the statues.
So this covers pretty thoroughly the statues
in America.
What about the equestrian statues across the
pond?
The Ancient Romans had numerous examples of
equestrian statues, but unfortunately nearly
all were destroyed or melted down for use
in other things.
One of the very few surviving equestrian statues
from Rome was of Emperor Marcus Aurelius who
died in 180 of an illness.
His horse in that statue has one foreleg up
in the air.
There is no record of Marcus Aurelius ever
being wounded in battle and as a prominent
Roman and eventual Emperor, it’s unlikely
he saw much direct, close-up battle time (though
was a part of many battles).
And if you’re wondering, probably the only
reason the statue of Marcus Aurelius survived
when most all the others did not is that for
a long time it was misidentified as a statue
of Emperor Constantine the Great, who was
a Christian Emperor.
Why is this important to its preservation?
Because many of the Roman statues were melted
down to make things like church bells, coins,
and sculptures for churches.
Melting down a statue of Constantine would
have been borderline blasphemy.
Given this, it’s perhaps no surprise to
learn that there is also a surviving equestrian
statue of Emperor Constantine, in this case
with the horse having both front legs up.
Constantine did not die in battle, rather
of natural causes.
Fast-forward to more recent times, in Medieval
Europe and there really aren’t many equestrian
statues, as they were (and are) very expensive
to make and require an exceptionally skilled
sculptor.
The few examples that exist don’t seem to
correlate at all with any sort of horse leg
tradition.
For one brief, slightly more recent example,
we have King Louis XIV who had an equestrian
statue at Versailles with both forelegs on
the horse in the air.
Louis XIV died of gangrene at the age of 77,
not in battle.
Given that many a sculptor has worked on equestrian
statues throughout history, if there is supposed
to be some sort of code, even if not generally
followed, there would be documentation of
it somewhere- after all, they have to pass
that code on.
Not surprisingly, there is not.
It’s almost as if the sculptor just chooses
the horse’s attitude to suit personal artistic
preference…
Bonus Facts:
• If a statue with a rider and horse is
called an “equestrian statue”, you might
be wondering what a statue of just a horse
is called.
That answer is an “equine statue”.
• “Equestrian” comes from the Latin
“eques”, meaning “knight”, which in
turn derives from “equus”, meaning “horse”.
• A much lesser known statue myth has to
do with European knights.
The myth goes that if the knight’s statue
or tombstone depicts them with their legs
or arms crossed, then the knight fought in
one of the Crusades.
The idea behind this is that crossing the
legs or arms represents the cross of Christ,
more or less that the soldiers “took up
their cross” to go fight in the Crusades.
As with the equestrian statue myth, there
is no evidence whatsoever to support this
notion.
• Another common myth you’ll hear many
a tourist guide around the equator say is
that what hemisphere you’re in effects the
way the water swirls down the toilet or drain.
They’ll even sometimes take you a few hundred
meters on one side of the equator and show
you water swirling one way, then a few hundred
meters from that on the other side of the
equator and show it swirling the other.
Magic!
In fact, of course, what hemisphere you’re
in has almost nothing to do with the way water
swirls down toilets
and drains.